à new york n'avait évidemment jamais
connu une telle apocalypse dans la
panique le maire a même vidé le sud de
la ville de ses habitants vous l'avez
entendu il parle d'un nombre de victimes
je cite terrifiant témoignages
rassemblés par patrick fandio
l'impensable vient de se produire
et c'est la panique
au coeur de manhattan dans les rues près
des deux tours du world trade center
chacun cherche un abri
[Applaudissements]
les policiers pensent qu'ils peuvent à 7
heures ce sont des milliers d'américains
qui se rendent au travail ou dans les
centres commerciaux tout près ce matin
ils vivent le drame en direct
l'effondrement des deux tours de verre
le long de l'hudson river cette femme
raconte qu'elle a entendu un gros boum
et après il ya eu une grosse fumée tout
le monde a essayé de sortir et on a vu
arriver un autre avion de l'autre côté
il y avait de la fumée partout et des
gens qui ont tenté de sortir par les
fenêtres dans les immeubles entre les
débris ce qu'ils ont pu trouver la porte
de sortie raconte l'incroyable
[Musique]
nous avons entendu une grosse explosion
tout est soudain devenu très sombre il y
avait des débris de verre qui tombait de
partout les gens étaient blessés c'était
une grosse explosion
tout était noir il y avait un nuage de
cendres comme de la neige mais vous le
voyez ce n'est pas de la neige c'est
l'immeuble c'était un cauchemar terry
après le crash du premier avion il y en
a eu un second ce ils venaient du sud et
a heurté la tour sud vers le haut de
l'immeuble
ça ne peut être qu'une action terroriste
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire
il ya eu une grosse explosion des gens
sont sortis à moitié dénudée et j'ai
tout fait pour essayer de les aider
c'est tout le sud de manhattan qui a été
évacué puis bouclé par des centaines de
policiers et de secouriste alors qu'un
nuage de cendres a sombré c'est toujours
la vitrine financières du monde